l'attitude de notre groupe est fière et
avait l'expression d'une colère d'une
révolte parce que depuis 2015 nous avons
fait 37 propositions de loi des
centaines d'amendements
nous avons toujours été vraiment une
force de proposition et jamais le
gouvernement n'a accepté de nous suivre
et c'était c'était sale nous exprimions
cette colère là il appartient au
gouvernement à la majorité d'écouter son
opposition
c'est ça la démocratie c'est pas d un
camp contre l'autre
surtout dans des moments aussi
dramatique que cela que ceux qui vivent
ce que nous ne ce qui nous interroge
beaucoup c'est la distance qui entre les
mots du président la république a su
nommer les choses par les d'islamisme de
radicalité
il a désigné l'ennemi qui nous a déclaré
la guerre
et cette proposition de loi gérald
darmanin nous a dit on ne parlera pas
une migration parlera pas de
radicalisation il ne faut pas
stigmatiser l'islam radical donc de quoi
parlons nous on a fait des propositions
extrêmement clair d'abord nous lions la
question de l'islamisme à l'immigration
il faut tarir une immigration qui
effectivement est beaucoup trop
importante et on voit bien que aussi
bien l'attentât devant charlie hebdo que
la mort de ce professeur est lié à des
jeunes qui sont issus de l'immigration
qui avait d'ailleurs qui faisait partie
d'une immigration irrégulière
si on ne tarit pas le flou l'immigration
parmi tous ces gens qui viennent sur
notre sol il ya en effet des radicaliser
il faut expulser
la clé c'est quand même que la france
retrouve sa capacité à expulser des gens
qui veulent nous nuit
il faut fermer dans une proportion
beaucoup plus importante les lieux de
culte radicaliser et puis puisque nous
parlant de la mort 2
de samuel pâtit il faut un délit d'
entrave d'enseignés par exemple mais
nous avons fait plus d'une dizaine de
propositions très très construite et
nous aimerions bien que le gouvernement
nous entende
il faut protéger les français il ya
manifestement aujourd'hui en france des
gens qui veulent nous imposer un mode de
pensée à mode de vie hameau d'enseignés
qui veulent restreindre notre liberté
qui veulent imposer leur loi et qui
veulent changer ce qu'est la france
profondément donc ça il faut se battre